this man's a comic genius I didn't know
that before and now I do
[Music]
snatched so snatched is a comedy
starring Amy Schumer Amy Schumer plays
Amy Schumer it's all those cases where
you see Amy Schumer in a movie you know
exactly the character she's going to
play and she plays like there
however this movie also sets you up to
be super selfish don't look to a
delusional degree I need to
compartmentalize those I'm not saying
Amy Schumer is super selfish true in
almost delusional degrade I'm just
saying among the constructs in this
movie that is Amy Schumer that's the
variable character it's also a selfish
piece of [ __ ] and after she comes by her
boyfriend her and her mom played by
Goldie Hawn go to this exotic vacation
in South America and they may get
kidnapped by these scumbag they get out
of it and now they have to escape and
that's the movie comedy that when I
walked out of I was kind of conflicted
because I was like that movie made me
laugh quite a few times but I have no
urge to see the movie again it's weird
to me I needed ready to think about this
I need to figure this [ __ ] out here it
is this movie made me laugh but that
laughter really never came from the main
characters on screen never really came
from Amy Schumer Goldie Hawn had a blend
of two rows like that surprisingly funny
Amy Schumer really never made me laugh
and I'm not on that Amy Schumer hate
train at all Amy Schumer has made me
laugh credit where credit's do she's
done and credit recruits do I like
trainwreck however in this movie is just
like she could have been played by
anybody not like you look at the script
of this movie you're like only Amy
Schumer could play that role it could
have been Jennifer Lawrence for all I
care give a [ __ ] I feel like she or a
lot of actresses could have done the
comedic moments Amy Schumer had to do in
this movie and again with the editing or
how many times this year 2017 alone have
you heard me speak the line or a phrase
something like this somewhere around the
middle of the movie there's a lot of
choppy
editing it's like the movie was longer
and they had to crush it down for the
sake of time [ __ ] that happened to my
last review King Arthur it also happens
in this movie there is a splice in this
movie that's so abrupt there's such an
abrupt time jump I thought she was
actually dreaming I was like I was going
to wake up from this dream and that'll
be that she never wakes up it's a really
weird editing choice what sets it apart
is usually you look at that you're like
oh that scene could have been longer and
could have benefited from it this time
you're like now why did they ever have
it
at all ever a lot of the locker in this
movie comes from the supporting and side
characters her brother in this movie
made me laugh a lot there's this banter
between him and his other day at the
Embassy on the phone is this running
joke goes on and on and it was
hysterical also this is Indiana Jones
wannabe dude he cracked me up he is my
favorite character in his movie should
have been in this movie for longer he
was so good guys in the end smashed was
alright all the good moments with Amy
Schumer they show in the trailer Goldie
Hawn has a couple of surprisingly good
moments to supporting crew the
supporting characters in Islam they make
this movie you're going to catch a catch
of that matinee I will say snacks would
probably be a better time if you were
drunk
ya know is the party doors is girls
going to the girls good yeah alright
guys so snatched have you seen it what
did you think about it was your favorite
parent-kid combo in a comedy whatever it
is whoever they are whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]